admitted sexual abuser dr. Larry
Nasser's latest sentencing hearing was
interrupted just minutes ago when the
father of three of NASA's accusers
rushed him in the courtroom I would ask
you to as part of the sentencing to
grant me five minutes and a lock would
you do that no sir would you give me one
minute you know that I can't do that
that's not how officers and Nasser's
lawyers managed to stop Randle
margrave's who was handcuffed and taken
from the courtroom the prosecutor then
told others waiting to testify
use your words are dr. Jon LaPook spoke
with another victim who received an
apology yesterday from police John good
morning good morning Nora the fallout
from the sexual abuse scandal shows no
sign of abating as questions remain
about who knew what when the Meridian
Township Police Department's failure to
believe breanne Randle was abused is
just the latest example to Brianna we
failed you we let you down Meridian
Township manager Frank Walsh issued the
apology to Brianne Randall Thursday I
know we've had a lot of private
conversations private apologies but we
felt this needed to be done in public
Randall who attended the news conference
via a live feed filed a report to local
police back in 2004 when she was 17
claiming Nasr sexually abused her
according to the police report released
Wednesday
Nasr admitted he touched Randall in the
genital area but created a PowerPoint
presentation for police to show the
procedure is a medical technique police
decided not to pursue charges do you
think what if what if they had just
believed me and pursued it I think what
if all the time though it's been
difficult Randall says she accepts the
department's apology having to come to
the realization that I was sexually
abused and because no one believed me
hundreds of other women were
subsequently abused
it's been a huge struggle for me in a
radio interview yesterday one of
Nasser's lawyers shannon smith seemed to
cast doubt on some of nasa's victims
there is a huge part of me that does not
believe that every one of those girls
was victimized by him Larry is the most
dangerous type of abuser Rachael den
Hollander the first Nasr victim to
publicly reveal her identity issued a
statement in response saying in part the
level of willful ignorance displayed by
Shannon Smith is beyond the pale
in a statement Nasser said he was not
aware that Smith's statements were going
to be made nor did he authorize them he
apologized for the distraction Smith
told CBS News she is not going to say
anything further as she believes her
statements have been blown into a
different context than they were meant
any egregious comments yeah Mary thank
you John